si vous êtes abonnés au téléphone
portable bouygues
je vous signale que tout le système est
en panne depuis 6 heures ce matin les
abonnés bouygues ne peuvent ni maître ni
recevoir d'appels on prend des nouvelles
du front tout de suite avec david
beaudry une panne nationale sur tout le
territoire c'est l'ensemble du réseau de
téléphonie mobile de bouygues telecom
qui est en rade sonnerie dans le vide ou
message indiquant que le numéro n'est
pas attribué depuis 6 heures ce matin
les trois millions 800 mille abonnés de
l'opérateur ne peuvent ni émettre ni
recevoir d'appels bouygues telecom d'y
mettre tout en oeuvre pour rétablir au
plus vite le service à ses clients
de plus un peu moins de trois heures le
112 le numéro d'urgence aurait déjà été
rétablie mais 70% des clients ne
reçoivent toujours pas d'appel à
l'origine de cette panne deux serveurs
informatiques qui serait tombée en
rideau les réparations sont en cours
mais bouygues telecom n'est pas en
mesure de dire à quelle heure seront
rétablis les communications en octobre
dernier une autre panne informatique
avait touché france télécom en région
parisienne notamment plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'abonnés avait du mal à
joindre leurs correspondants depuis leur
téléphone fixe